dernières retouches de cette fresque
monumentale sur l'histoire du quartier
ovalie boua plaisir depuis 2016 la
société cité création est missionnée par
la ville et les résidences yvelines
essonne pour embellir les façades par la
particularité ici c'est il ya deux
dynamiques et dynamique culturelle on a
travaillé avec plus de 50 cultures
différentes
donc c'est très riche mais c'est rare
d'avoir une telle diversité donc il nous
a été très cher pendant sur toutes les
oeuvres créées surtout les sept fraysse
d'évoquer cette diversité et ensuite
également celle approche de rénovation
urbaine de la ville de plaisir c'est à
dire que le quartier du val hibou mais
également la ville de plaisir et dans
une recomposition urbaine globale et que
donc ses fresques aussi vocation à
travailler sur une attractivité
une ouverture qui va complètement
recomposée la ville dans la décennie qui
vient
cette sixième fresque sera terminée dans
quelques jours avant le démarrage d'un
septième et dernier chantier ici fin
octobre début novembre
mais avant de monter le moindre
échafaudage l'entreprise réalise une
concertation avec les habitants
l'objectif que les fresques représentent
la vie du quartier et les désirs de ces
résistants mardi 24 septembre il dévoilé
aux élèves du collège blaise pascal la
maquette de la dernière fresque sur le
thème des saveurs thème choisi par les
collégiens
elle est bien franchement bahia
plusieurs fouilles barbus aux duvalier
vous par exemple moi ma grand mère elle
y avait deux là bas et j'ai vu vise à
baser ce qui est tout temps ils boivent
là bas donc bah moi j'aime bien c'est
bien de représenter ses valeurs
serveur et que les autres presque aussi
sont bien je sens que ça va apporter
peut-être y aura plus de gens qui vont
venir voir des fresques pour ouvrir le
quartier sur l'extérieur des visites ont
d'ailleurs déjà été organisées lors de
ses dernières journées européennes du
patrimoine